cole calhoun in the arizona diamondbacks
in town for a three-game series it's
always nice to see players come back
home for the first time and see their
former teammate julio tehran this will
be his eighth appearance seventh start
of the season still looking for that
first win wearing that angels uniform
cole calhoun sort of robbed of his home
coming here normally he'd be getting
quite a big hand from angels fans but of
course they're all made of cardboard
lead at first by walker
oh calhoun speaking of bombs cole
calhoun is back in town
that's number 10 and it's two nothing
diamondbacks what a return to orange
county for cole calhoun other than the
lack of fans i'm sure cole calhoun's
been thinking about that swing for a
long time wow no doubter to right center
field madison bumgarner still looking
for win number one ass d-back not hard
to figure out the home runs have been
the biggest issue so far the angels have
their lead off paint on board jared at a
286 average with five home runs 13 runs
bounded in just over the glove of walker
and goes up the line
there goes fletcher running into third
and he will stop they know he's going to
come through the sign he's headed home
he's in there
lance barrett says fletcher is safe he
scores all the way from first
and walsh is standing at second let's
see if the run stands
bella will challenge the safe call david
fletcher mike trout anthony rendon and
albert pujols do up with nobody out in
the inning and you take that chance he
is out at home diamondbacks win the
challenge take that run off the board
mad bum facing mike trout for the first
time in their careers and madison is
ahead no balls and two strikes he hit
him on the elbow he plunked trout two on
and one down now for anthony randon
there's a ground ball hit sharply to
second rojas then on to first sending
any double play two up two down here in
the second inning two quick outs here
and there's dalton varsio
varsha launches one right field
goodbye dalton varsio his third and it's
three nothing diamondbacks playing some
long ball at angel stadium wow was that
ball just mashed i mean right right in
his happy zone there and he just jumped
all over it now kelly goes deep to left
field that ball is going to get out of
here carson kelly hits one right after
var show d backs go back to back their
third of the night off to rod in two
innings and the lead is four to nothing
here
we're gonna play home run derby tonight
i like this three of them already and
here's goal to on to no ounce they honor
cole here on the scoreboard they can
cole and
everyone's tell them to get up but thank
everybody get up on that top deck such a
popular player with the angels for all
those years
old calhoun there's another line drive
to right and he did it again
cole calhoun two at bets and two home
runs
back in angel stadium and the
diamondbacks have a seven nothing lead
wow
cole calhoun coming back to haunt the
angels right out of the gate here
five rbis already for calhoun that three
run blast this is a curveball again that
just is right in the middle of the plate
jared walsh with the double bounced over
the head of the first baseball that is
pulled down the right field lines got a
chance to get out of here and that is
gone big fly for jared walsh a line
drive home run and he has homered again
boy what a tear he's been on for the
angels that's his sixth of the season
jared walsh hit 409 on that last road
trip with four home runs walsh with home
runs in five of his last six games and
he's been hitting some homers against
lefties which is encouraging as well the
all on pitch
on the way and smith hits one to right
and back making the catch war there's a
tag by kelly and he hustles to the plate
and there's the first big league rbi off
the bat of haven smith diebacks get that
run back and it's eight to one second
and third with nobody out in field back
the 10. that is pulled past the first
baseman walker
that'll bring home two runs walsh is
trying to get the second base to throw
from calhoun a good one and safe at
second base and now anthony rendon will
be the next batter that's pulled down
the left field line another extra base
hit
walsh will score easily rindon is on his
way to second and the lead is cut in
half it's eight to four down my backs
justin upton with an opportunity here
and this ball is driven deep down the
left side it's well hit and it is out of
here boy the angels are getting back in
this ball game it's now eight to six
arizona and still plenty of ball game
left
11 hits pop bomb garner imagine there's
a short leash here junior garrosh up
with the pulpit getting ready pulled
toward third base that's a fair ball
headed to the corner simmons will turn
he'll head to second rbi double and the
angels are down one fletcher pulls this
one down the left field line make that
13 hits an extra base hit another one
we're tied up at eight
just a little puzzle to why bumgar still
out there on the mound tie game at eight
and former dieback matt andres is on to
the lead off hitter david peralta
peralta sends one out to right field and
that's gone david peralta sends one out
of here off matt andres and the
diamondbacks who let an eight to one
lead get away go ahead nine to eight
stephon crichton who will get the ninth
inning here tonight stefan got his first
save this year friday against seattle at
chase field when he came on and
protected a one-run lead in what turned
out to be a 4-3 d-backs win
this is a big boy save right here if
creighton can nail it down
and a fly ball to left
and there is peralta he's got it
diamondbacks won it nice win tonight up
8-1 they hang on and get a brawl to home
run of the eighth inning to win it 9-8